Hi, everyone.
At first I'm like,
literally shaking.
Those talks were so good.
How am I supposed
to follow that up?
But now I don't do
hashtag sports ball,
but that is a layup where
this is going to be great.
So today's talk is going to
be about creating a design
system for Shiny and
R Markdown, which
I've called #onbrand.
I don't care if your
company is 100 people
or you have multiple
clients that you're
trying to manage or
just yourself having
a consistent and cohesive UI.
Greg might not hate it.
So this talk is coming
from a very selfish place.
I work with a lot
of clients where
I'll look at their
websites and we'll
see eight different
styled buttons
all performing the same action.
So I've kind of provided
this like scholastic "compare
what's different in these
photos" of a bad and good UI.
So in our don't do this,
you'll see the top image
and the bottom image
are different sizes.
Why why why why. You have header
text under both images that
are different sizes, different
colors and different opacities
I'm literally getting hives
just thinking about this.
There's a bunch here.
I'll leave that to you.
These slides are
available for free.
So Greg talked about
incredible rules.
But I am not a designer.
I'm a programmer
and I want rules
that I can govern my code by.
So I'm going to talk
about a design system
and what is a design system?
I got you.
It's a set of rules,
constraints and principles
implemented in design and code.
Let's walk through
an example here.
A rule for color
would be that you
have to pass a minimum
color contrast ratio
for accessibility legibility.
If you're going to put
text on a background,
I have to be able to read that.
Now, a constraint of
that is going to be these
are my colors in
my color palette.
I am a millennial.
I love pink that this is
going to be my color palette
for the rest of this talk.
And that's also my
guiding principle
that I'm just leaning in
to loving these two colors.
There's there can be a
whole conference itself
in color theory and why you
should use green or whatever.
But your principle can
also just be as simple
as like, I like Barbie.
A little bit more
informative here.
Shiny twist is an
error message, right?
That's something
really important
that you want to
leverage to your users.
So you're going to use
a bright, bold color
to denote that. You'll
see my background color
and the text color
are legible enough
that you can read that text.
And then my governing
principle, again,
is that red is important.
And my eye is going to
go straight towards that.
So the set of rules,
principles and the constraints,
you're going to apply that
to all the things, not just
color. Spacing:
How tightly are you going
to pack those things
that Greg just taught us,
we should put together?
Do you want to let them breathe?
Do you want or should
they be really tight?
Typography I overheard at lunch
one of the most incredible
developers I know, using a
PowerPoint slide deck, and
he was like, "I just changed my
font from the default.
And now it looks
like I have a brand."
Yes typography, Yes.
Yes queen.
Yes. So all these
things are important
and we can use all of these
components of our system
to create components.
And we're going
to use those reusable
components inside page layouts.
Do you need a visual?
I do.
So here's a component.
Let's say it's a button.
I'm going to apply my rules,
constrain some principles
to this button.
Now in Shiny-land,
which we all are now,
we can create a Shiny
module like a plot that
always lives with this button.
These this code
always lives together.
And then finally, I can
put those reusable modules
inside my entire page layout.
So, but that pink little
cutie is always the same one
and will always be using
that one all the time.
Not eight different
buttons, please.
So that takes us
to a design kit.
It's a collection of
assets that contains
a set of design elements such
as UI components and styles.
So Joe did a ton of heavy
lifting for me yesterday.
Thank you so much
that I don't have
to talk about the basics
of HTML and Greg's hashtag.
No HTML, no CSS.
Where my nerds at like yes,
we want to learn these things.
So if you use tags dollar
sign button in the console
and see what that prints
out, that's your HTML
that Joe was talking about.
And this is the ugly button
that you get with vanilla HTML.
But she's reliable and faithful.
You get this pointer
when you scroll
over it, a thick, dark border
and a gray kind of background
color.
So that's a vanilla HTML button.
But now we have an action button
and hearken back to Joe's talk
where you have HTML
and actions if x do y.
But what Joe didn't
talk about and Greg did
was that we also get CSS
for free using Bootstrap.
We were opting into
a design system.
Thank you so much.
This button is already
so much better.
When I hover over it, the
background turns gray.
How is this happening?
My HTML element has classes that
bootstrap is going to leverage.
I urge you the best way to
learn this stuff is like play
with it, break it, and
the rest of my talk
is going to be the
journey of doing
that to create my super
extra button, that I am,
again, I don't want
to be put in a box.
My buttons are
going to be round.
I have my pink text
and my pink background
and I call this
button primary_btn.
So we're going to make a package,
R code *sigh*, I can do this,
we're going to make a
package and in this package
we're going to put
all of our assets.
But again, this is the
journey of our humble button.
So this is a root
directory of our package
and we have an R file for
our button, a CSS file,
and then within an inst
folder we'll have a CSS
file and a JavaScript file.
Because I want to
give you in this talk
pedagogically all the
things you don't necessarily
need all these, but you'll
have the code, can play with it.
So let's start in R...
If there's one thing
I want you to take from this
talk, it's probably this slide.
Love that for you.
Take a Shiny input and then
you can use the function
tagListAppendAttribute to
put your own classes
on those HTML elements.
So it's like, psych, I don't want
to use bb's bslib or whatever.
I'm going to use my
own thing that I'm
making from scratch because
I'm stubborn, I'm a developer,
and then we can use this
wonderful magical function,
HTML tools, HTML dependency
to which essentially says,
take that JavaScript
file and that CSS file.
And now when you
render that button,
you get those for free
along for the ride.
So now I can just
call primary button
in my Quarto, R
Markdown, Shiny app.. .
They're all going to look
and feel the same because you
get all that in your list
object, chef's kiss.
Beautiful. So that's our button.
Now for the CSS, I
really just want you
to focus on the first
three lines here.
primary_btn was
the class I gave
it that is this whole
first three line
is in CSS is called a rule.
And in that rule we're
going to say "Apply
to my class of primary_btn,
the value
of background color, white or
pink, whatever, in my case.
And here's where you're going
to lay out all the CSS that you
want for your button.
I am not Greg.
I am not a designer.
This talk is not
To tell you
what color pink to
look and why you
hate the things that you do.
That's your own journey.
But I just want to give
you the tools to get up
and running with this,
right? And I want
you to also think
about different states in CSS.
So we have this concept
of pseudo selectors.
So not only am I
styling the button,
I need to think about hovering.
I need to think about
people who are not
using keyboard for navigation.
And if they're using
tab, how do you
know where you are in the page?
That's a focus state.
You'll get usually a heavy ring
around it and then disabled.
I can't click this button.
What does that look like?
So I want you to focus on
the button itself, but also
these different states.
And then lastly is
a JavaScript file.
I'm not going over this.
It's kind of just a Flex that
I can do this. My button,
when you click on the
button, it creates
this little ripple effect.
Again, slides, play
with it, have fun.
But I just wanted
to show you, you
can attach JavaScript and
do more things there, too.
All right.
This is my Easter egg slide.
If you click on this,
you get my design kit,
which is a Markdown of
all the elements here.
And I don't have time for that.
You guys all have computers.
I want to talk about my
two favorites in the
kit. In the kit, you're
going to put the output.
I need to see what it
looks like, but also
the code because if it's not
documented, it doesn't exist.
So document.
And why I want to show these
off is because they're so cute.
So when I hover over this
input, it turns black.
And then when I'm inside that
input, my label turned pink
and that was hard.
So please let me
have this moment.
Another thing I
wanted to show is
you can really
have a lot of voice
and what I'm going
to call, or what
are called, micro interactions.
I for my tab panel here,
I wanted a little swoop.
Swoop I think that's really fun.
These little micro animations
are a really lively way
to set up your slides, but
you don't want to go too crazy
and turn it into a
PowerPoint deck with, like,
animations all over the place.
So this is kind of take a
picture it'll last longer slide
of elements to include in your
UI kit: navbar, tabs, buttons...
Go ahead, smash
that Like button.
Perhaps not needed in
an academic setting.
So you don't need that
in your presentation,
but other elements here that
you can take away from this.
And then lastly,
this is all standing
on the shoulders
of giants here, who
have written incredible books
on how to integrate JavaScript
and CSS in HTML and R.
And then I wanted to also
plug this incredible book,
Refactoring UI, which has
amazing visuals for like,
why does this bother me
and this looks great?
And with that, I just
want to Thank everyone.
It's been so awesome to be here
and hanging out with everyone
has been incredible.
So thank you.